long lines outside Havana's petrol
stations have become a grim reality in
recent years but soon they may be a
thing of the past the Communist party
has announced the price of petrol will
soon increase
fivefold when the price of fuel goes up
everything gets more expensive if people
need to go to hospital or travel
somewhere it's going to cost them
more petrol prices won't rise until next
month but just the announcement has made
an impact how much did it cost you to
get to your house before from here to my
house 50 pesos and
now 150 they've all put their prizes
up these price hikes are part of what
the Communist party is calling a
macroeconomic stabilization program with
us sanctions choking off hard currency
inflows like never before real salaries
are
plummeting Cuba's President says he's
managing a war
economy this is not a package of
neoliberal measures against the people
nor is it a Crusade against small
businesses nor the elimination of the
basic basket of
goods this economist says an adjustment
program should have been done years ago
to correct major distortions in the
Island's economy but that it's better
late than
never raising prices and reducing
subsidies is an austerity program the
government isn't able to keep spending
on these things is an adjustment program
necessary or is there another
option I'd say it has to be
implemented all cuin are titled to basic
food rations at cheap prices at the
country's famous bodas but that's set to
change too food rations will be targeted
to vulnerable
groups water electricity and gas prices
have been low for decades encouraging
wasteful consumption isn't it expensive
to leave the gas on all the time no no
no not at all rather than buy a lighter
it's better for me to leave it on the
whole time and spend the money on a few
pounds of sweet potatoes or some
bananas but higher utility bills will
mean less money for food this homes
water bill is the equivalent of just 15
cents a month but that's no Small Change
in a country where the average salary
has fallen to the equivalent of just $17
a month people are already feeling the
pinch and they're worried about the
coming price
hikes and with the economy creaking
essential food rations have started
arriving
late the rice at the Russian store
hasn't come in yet this month so I have
a bit of rice left from last month so
I'll still have a bit to
eat as politicians tell the
long-suffering public to further Tyson
their belts Cubans are bracing for a
tough year ahead Ed Augustin Al jazer
Havana
Cuba make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaer